the way memory works is in terms of
snapshots I don't remember the entire
experience
I remember moments in that experience
and why is that so critical because it
tells you that what you need to manage
is not the film but it's specific kind
of moment what people most remember is
that end overall people rate
colonoscopies that take longer but end
less painfully better than colonoscopies
that are shorter but end more painfully
it doesn't matter how long something
took it matters how it ended they
remember the end which we've talked
about but they also remember the peak
it's something called a peak an end rule
people take those two pieces of
information and that's how they remember
an experience you can think of you know
you go to Disney you you go on the ride
that's an OP and then you wait in line
that sit down you know you go from sort
of location or location it's not kind of
a uniform experience that has all kinds
of spikes okay and it has it has kind of
moments in which experiences naturally
break up so if you think in terms of
peak and end you want to break up an
experience when when you're near the top
of something right so then when I think
back as a customer about my entire
experience what I've coded in my head is
a series of peak moments a lot of
companies forget the importance of
finishing strong hotels they'll do a lot
for you when you come in but then when
you check out that process isn't really
managed right it would actually be smart
and appropriate for them to give you a
departure gift so remember any kind of
customer experience that you have go
back to your desk after this webinar and
ask yourself how do we finish how does
this thing in understand how consumers
experience and rewire your approach to
product strategy learn more about
innovative product leadership the
emerging chief product officer